my husband and I we have been together
for 25 years but fun fact he was my
boyfriend in eighth grade before it was
time to go to high school my sister told
me who's six years older than me she was
like oh girls a lot of boys at high
school you don't want a boyfriend when
you go to high school and so I broke up
with him because I told him I was like
my sister said it's a lot of boys over
at the high school so you know I gotta
go keep my options open and he hated me
in high school would not look at me nor
talk to me however
After High School after we graduated we
became friends again got back together
and we had been together ever since
but honey he's gonna hate that he's like
oh you always bring it up he's still
holding on to it even though he got me
he's still holding on to it 25 years
later